welcome back i'm here with one of my
heroes and shark tank star mark cuban
you're so much more than shark tank
you're just everything including a
future president i hope anyway it's
pasta week on our show are you a pasta
fan i love pasta and it's one of the few
things i can cook and i'm one of those
guys that's just like literally throws
the spaghetti up against the wooden
cabinet to see if it sticks that way i
know it's done al dente
perfect well there are a lot of pasta
inventions out there gadgetry um ways in
which to cook we have a little rack here
that hangs the pasta um and a device
that also cuts
portions for
like lasagna which is actually brilliant
because lasagna doesn't really have a
lot of rules and how you make it and how
you present it and we have an inventor
here who wants to showcase his pasta
product and get a few business tips from
you if that's possible of course all
right greg get singer will you please
get out here
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
how are you i'm so happy to meet you so
happy to meet you are you tripping out
that like shark tank music is playing
we're here and this gentleman is here
it's unbelievable i know i'm having a
totally surreal moment pinch me too
pinch me okay see
what
well um greg since we have mark's
attention and the luxury of it tell us
about your product um
my product is is for lasagna is for
portioning pans of lasagna into equal
portions when i invented this product
it's because i used to have experience
in the
restaurant industry owned my own pizza
business
and portioning it was very important
this is very simple to use and very easy
to do and it makes life a lot easier is
this designed more for commercial or
in-home um i i've designed it for a
commercial
but
it is something that i want to bring to
the retail market because it's so simple
to use and even in the
evening
in the homes uh home foodies who bake
and cook you have to have simple to use
uh tools sure so will you show us how to
do that yeah you just uh slide it on but
you'll notice that it'll snap in place
so it doesn't move around there we go
got it yeah so there it's nice in place
all you have to do is grab yourself look
it through with it it's like
you can't be see and you don't have to
use a knife you can use a spatula
because you're going to have to use a
spatula to pull it out anyway anyways
right
you just cut through it up
also i don't know
where the bottom of the pan so you know
it's done exactly
see it's very simple to cut right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and you can also play tic-tac-toe
well there's also a
those are for the bigger portions you
can also i have a portion paddle that's
uh a lasagna portion pedal that's also
made to do nine portions it's two of
them okay so we just pull it up lift it
up they're all cut into equal portions
oh it's not even really dirty either so
yeah because i know i'm not going to
clean it anyways
now these are bigger portions and that's
where the nine uh portion portion panel
uh lasagna portion paddle comes into
play big old portion yes it is
but my wife when she makes her life
lasagna the the we either use the bigger
portion a smaller portion depending on
how many people are sitting at the table
um mark thoughts
i think it's cool right i mean
commercial i can definitely see it right
because you want a portion control and
you want consistency right so that's why
you did at home
you know
i grew up three boys so we would have
been fighting so this would have been
great because we already got the same
size pizza so then the question is how
much does it cost to buy and where can i
buy it well it's on the commercial it's
on my website at www.portionpaddle.com
that's you can spell it either way
p-a-d-d-l-e
or p-a-d-l which is my portion
paddle.com.com right yes and how much
does it cost um on the the the
commercial cost is 134.95
consumer um i'm going to run a special
uh for anybody out there and it'll be
for 82.95 so it's not cheap but it's
effective right right it's not cheap but
i could the assign you portion panel i
it can be scaled
to a lower price with a little bit more
volume right well we pulled our audience
actually to see how likely they would be
to purchase
this paddle and 81 of our audience said
that they would buy it damn
greg that is like
that's insane well done it's nice to be
able to test the water and the
temperature and see that there is
interest there
mark would you be so kind um is to maybe
um give greg some advice at some point
of course yeah you know your honest
opinion behind the scenes yeah i'll get
you all my information off off screen
and yeah wonderful yeah whatever i can
do to help you i'm happy to do it i love
to help entrepreneurs thank you greg
singer and next time
i'm telling you thank you so much
and mark
timing is everything i have waited a
very long time to meet you
i was always so drawn to not just your
light
but your intention
and you've been such a fearless leader
you've helped extend yourself to teach
others how to find their dreams and i
find it so admirable
that you don't believe in shortcuts you
believe in treating people well along
the way that in itself might be one of
the most valuable lessons that you give
out as well as many others thank you so
much thank you i'm so happy to meet you
congratulations greg good job good job
all right mark cuban shark tank airs
friday 8 7 central
on abc
and we'll be right back
[Music]